那么各位同学大家好
欢迎来到我们今天的直播
我们也是刚刚开播啊
那么先热热场啊
刚刚给大家解解梦
那么你们也可以在评论区
给我们打一个招呼啊
让我知道你们都在啊
让我知道你们都在
大家可以打一个我在啊
那么今天呢
我们的直播有这么一个主题啊
这个主题是两个字
叫做情绪
就是你会发现
在我们的日常生活里边啊
很多时候
真正让我们痛苦的不是事情的本身
而是你的情绪没有处理好
你看有的人在关系里边啊
他等不到对方的改变
他就会一直一直的失望对吧
有的人背着这种恨在过日子
所以他活着很累那
有的人因为焦虑
那晚上睡不好觉
对吧
还有人呢
总是因为别人的一句话不开心很久
但我想告诉大家
情绪这个东西
它并不是敌人
它是什么呢
大家打两个字叫做信号
来
信号
它其实是一种信号
一种提醒
甚至是一种推动我们成长的
这么一个力量
只要你懂得方法
我告诉你
你就能把情绪变成帮助你的人
而不是困住你的
那么接下来
我会带着大家
一步步的走过8个情绪的主题
从关系里边的痛苦
到如何面对失望
如何可以放下这种仇恨
再到焦虑不开心的应对方法
那我们今天的目标很简单
就是希望今天早上这场直播
你听完以后
不仅仅只是懂得了道理
而是正儿八经的
对吧咱们能够学会几个实用的技巧
随时啊
能够把自己从情绪里边拉出来啊
大
家准备好了吗
那我们马上开始
有位同学说昨天刚刚分手
今天心情很差
我爱过他
现在很痛苦
因为我生病了
他可以有更好的选择
昨天说他想要自由
我成全了
请老师帮我
啊怎么帮你呢
对不对
我告诉他所有
我告诉你所有的问题
只有一句话
不是他不变
而是你还在等
这句话能理解吗
啊
老师今天的直播有回放吗
会员的同学是有回放的啊
有回放
我还没开始讲
大家就问有没有回放
好吧啊
如何做自己的父母5天特训营
来听一听
5天特训营第几天
第二天讲如何做自己的父母啊
我再说一遍
不是他不变
或者不是他改变
是你还在等
所以问题在哪
等他改变
不如你转身
在亲密关系里边
很多人都会遇到这样的问题
对方为什么不肯改变
我已经说过无数次
他还是老样子
我明明很努力
为什么我们还是走不下去呢
答案其实很残酷
一个人不愿意改变
我告诉你
全世界都无法改变他
他不够好
你可以离开他
但很多人是他不够好
我要改变他
那我告诉你
成败这事就不是你说了算了
而是他在操控了
那我说的更直白一点
如果说对方真的不够好
你有两个选择
要么接受
要么离开
可是现实中很多人他舍不得离开呀
但是他又忍受不了痛苦
所以他会很内耗
会纠缠
他可能希望用自己的耐心
用自己的眼泪
用自己的妥协来换对方的转变
得吧但我想你一定要明白
这是一条死路
为什么
因为改变这个东西
从来不是外力的强加
而是他自己愿意
那你说宋明老师
我们还能做什么呢
我告诉大家只有一条路
就是把主动权交还给自己
而不要把希望压在别人身上
在两性关系里边
有一句非常扎心的话
叫做谁痛苦谁改变
换句话说
如果你是那个痛苦的人
那就意味着调整的人必须是你
而不是继续苦苦等待别人来配合你
你可以尝试去做一些事
让他在这段关系里边
感受到能够值得留下来的价值
能理解吗
你可以设身处地的想一想
如果你自己是那个已经心里想走的人
对方做什么你会留下来
你告诉我
假如说跟你在一起的感觉
比外面更多的可能性
更糟糕的话
那他肯定会走
你也肯定会离开
但如果说这里比外面更温暖更值得
那我相信你也会选择留下来
所以关键不是在于说服对方改变
而是你要睁开你的眼睛
看清楚现实
这段关系是否还真的有留存的意义
你是否能够在这个过程里边
调整自己的心态
你的界限和你的选择
痛苦从来都不是敌人
痛苦是什么
大家打一句话来
这句话痛苦是通往成功的营养啊
痛苦从来都不是敌人
他其实是提醒你
你该醒了
你该动了
真正的力量不是等对方变
不是等对方回头
而是你在学会痛苦中成长
学会转身
学会选择
所以你们记住一句话
爱可以包容
但不等于无限的忍耐
关系能不能继续
不在于他会不会变
而是在于你是否敢为自己改变
啊
那么回答了刚才那个同学的问题
觉得有收获的
咱们打一个7字来
啊
在梦里边经常被抛弃
没有安全感了
也没有归属感了
那你在生活里边经常会找价值感
对吧
嗯
很多时候
就是我们对关系会有一种期待
但是这种期待是什么
大家打一句话
期待是失望的源头
哼
这句话大家能理解吧
啊
就是你会发现
不管你多么努力的去拉扯一个人
他都不会因为你的期待而改变的
可能是你的伴侣
也可能是你的孩子
也可能是你的父母
所以你看
你开始在一次次的等待和落空之间
不断的消耗自己
这个才是内耗的来源
那你失望肯定不可避免了呀
对吧但你想一想
失望真的是来自于对方吗
大家告诉我来
你的失望是来自于对方吗
嗯
啊
田一啊点击我的头像
然后点击客服啊
然后留言给我
其实
它更多的来自于我们自己放弃了选择
对吧你把期望
你把希望完全寄托在别人身上了
所以我觉得我们怎么面对失望
也是一个非常重要的这么一个课题
我们接下来讲一讲好不好
如何把失望
变成一个成长的这么一个契机
啊
失望其实就一句话
人或者事儿没有按我的意愿发生
对吧这句话能理解吗
生活里边最容易引发失望的地方
就是人与人的关系
婚姻朋友工作伙伴都会遇到你
比方说你约了一个朋友
两点见面
他答应的好好的
结果呢没
来你心里边很难过啊
甚至开始抱怨他怎么能这样呢
怎么能不守信用呢
但我想请大家冷静的想一想
这个人
可能本来就是一个说话不算数的人
他没来是他的选择
你管得了他的人生吗
你真正能够管理的只有你自己
你选择相信他
是你的人生决定
你感到失望
也是因为你把期待放到了他的身上
所以重点不是他做了什么
而是你要如何处理这份失望
但我想告诉大家
所有负面情绪都有它的正面价值
那你说宋明老师
失望怎么能够把它变成正面价值啊
我跟你们说几点第一点
你认清了一个事实了
这人他不能深交
对吧那以后交朋友
你就有了新的判断标准了
你不会再轻易的相信他的承诺了呀
这是第一个
第二个你也会明白
他没来
我依然有能力照顾好自己的人生啊
我完全可以安排时间
去做别的有意义的事
而不要把自己困在等待和失望里边
所以换句话说
每一次的失望都是一次人生的提醒
他告诉你
不要再把选择交到别人的手里
你要学会管理自己的情绪
学会收回主动权
因为你总有选择的
只是当你放弃选择的时候
你才有机会去抱怨别人
对吗
所以
抱怨让你变成了一个可怜虫的状态
好像一切都不由自己决定
但事实上
我告诉你
人生从来都不是被动的
大家把这句话打出来
你可以选择不再期待不靠谱的人
你可以选择把精力放在更值
得的关系上啊
你可以选择把那份失望
转化成让自己更轻松
更满足更快乐的经验呐
所以大家记住一句话
失望不可怕
真正可怕的是你忘了自己还有选择
啊大家打一打
是不是这样啊
嗯
你要知道
就是当这种失望积累的越来越多
如果说你没有好好的处理它
就会演变成另外一种更加严重的情绪
叫什么呢
叫做恨怨恨
失望最容易转的情绪就是恨
啊
你可能会觉得我恨他
对吧
是对对方的一种惩罚
但事实上我告诉你
恨只会让你自己被困住
就像拖着很沉重的这个船锚在走路
累的是谁呀
你觉得累的是是是别人吗
我告诉大家
累的永远是你自己
所以问题来了呀
如何才能真正的走出这种困境啊
那我们接着来聊一聊
就是恨这件事
为什么放下他
不是放过别人
而是什么呀
放下恨是放下什么呀
是放过自己
自己
很多人都会认为
恨能够给自己力量
能让对方付出代价
但真相恰恰相反
恨不会让别人怎样
却会慢慢的耗尽你自己
你想一想
有一艘巨大的游轮
本来可以轻松的驶向远方
可是如果拖着一个很沉重的船锚
它能走得远吗
你心里边的那份恨
我告诉你
就是这个船锚
你越是紧紧抓着不放
人生的每一步就越沉重
越痛苦所以
放下恨不是放过别人
而是放过自己
有些人会说
我太无辜了呀
对吧我没有责任呢
但只要你拒绝去看到
自己在事情中一部分责任
我告诉你
你就会越来越委屈
越陷在仇恨里边出不来呀
c首要想走出来
第一步就是承认
我在其中也有学习的空间
这个不是责怪自己
而是让自己有能力往前走啊
你要问自己啊
我能不能够把每一次心里有恨的事
当成一个台阶
让我走的更高
这完全是可以做到的
事情发生了
对吧我们无法改变
可这件事对我的人生的意义
是永远可以重新定义的
这就是一种选择
你比方说你做生意被别人骗了1,000万
这个损失你可能拿不回来
这是事实
但是你有两种活法
第一种带着恨夜夜难眠
10年以后身体被拖垮
命短10年
第二种你告诉自己
钱没了可以再赚回来
更重要的是
我从这次的失败里边我学到了什么
下次我一定更成功
你觉得哪一种对你来说更划算呢
答案显而易见
所以真正的智慧是明白发生过的事
你改变不了
但它的意义
我们永远都有权选择
选择带着恨
只会赔的更多
选择放下
才有可能转亏为盈
所以记住
放下仇恨并不是饶恕对方
而是给自己一份轻松和自由
你的人生不是用来背负仇恨的
而是用来走的更远更好的
所以只有你放下仇恨的那一刻
我告诉大家
你才会感觉到两个字叫做轻松
但这并不意味着生活里边没有痛苦
对吧
无论是这种身体上的伤
还是心理上的痛
我觉得都会不断的出现啊
欢迎来到宋明讲心理的这么一个直播
间啊
如果觉得宋明老师刚刚讲的这番话啊
对大家来说是有帮助的
也希望大家每天都来听一听
一定要订机啊
一定要点击订阅我们的频道
每一天
我们都会有大量的这种新的输出啊
希望能够在某一句话能够唤醒你
那么这也是我们期待的
我相信也是你期待的啊
加完关注以后
不要忘了点亮这个粉丝牌
加一加咱们的这个粉丝团啊
欢迎大家
欢迎大家啊
谢谢大家的关注啊
谢谢大家的关注
对我们一边点赞一边听来
今天点赞的数量比较少啊
比较少来点点赞来啊
嗯
很多人啊
他会他会很害怕痛
他觉得痛是敌人
其实我想告诉大家
痛这个东西
它是救你的信号
能理解吗
就它会提醒你有危险哎
它提醒你需要改变啊
如果说没有痛觉
我们就会被伤害吞噬
所以接下来
我们用一个更深一点的视角
我们来看一看
去理解一下
痛苦就痛苦
这个东西到底
是要告诉我们什么
它真的是这种通往成功的营养吗
很多人都害怕痛
无论是身体的痛还是心里的痛
我们第一反应都是两个字
逃避
但你有没有想过
其实痛本身就是生命在提醒你
有危险了
对吧该改变了
我举个最简单的例子
假如你的手放在火盆上
你马上会感觉到剧烈的痛
正是这种痛
逼得你立刻把手缩回来
如果说没有痛觉
我告诉你
你还以为一切正常
直到手被烧坏
甚至连命都保不住
对吧所以痛的作用其实很大的
它不是来惩罚你
而是推动你找出一个摆脱威胁的方向
痛是在提醒你快点处理
它就是生命的警报器
大家打一打
痛是生命的警报器
抑郁也一样
焦虑也一样啊
同样的道理
放在心理上也一样
当你在感情里边觉得焦虑被忽视
被压抑
这些心理上的痛苦其实就是信号
他告诉你哎
这段关系可能出了问题啊
你需要采取行动了
你不要继续麻木下去啊
可是很多人
他选择了另外一条路
装没事
或者是压抑
要么装没事
要么压抑
训练自己的麻木
好像无论多痛
我都能强忍着不去理会
但问题就是
麻木不是解决啊
而是慢性的自毁
就像手放在火里边不觉得痛
最后只会更快的坏掉
心里的麻木一样
它可能毁掉的不只是当下的关系
更会毁掉整个人生
所以同学们
当痛苦来临的时候
别急着逃
也不要骗自己
真正的智慧不是压抑
而是勇敢面对
问自己这份痛在提醒我什么
大家打出来
这份痛在提醒我什么
啊
他要我看见
要我改变的是什么
所以记住
痛不是敌人
它是守护你的生命的信号
正是因为感受到痛
我们才有机会避开危险
找到新的方向啊
如果你觉得这番话对你有收获的话
不要忘了关注我们
也不要忘了转发一下
所以痛让我们能够停下来
提醒我们要调整方向
但调整方式不同
那我跟你说
结果也不一样
很多人遇到痛
他就会用愤怒来回应
想要通过掌控去
抵消那份无力感
但你要知道
越想控制
越会挫败
愤怒也越大呀
所以真正的力量并不是
怎么说呢
对吧刚硬的掌控
我觉得是像水一样的柔性
老子说什么上善若水
那么我们接着来聊一聊
至柔才至刚啊
那这也是我们在觉察情绪里边
对吧
最为实用的这么一招啊
很多时候啊
我们会突然冒出一种愤怒
其实愤怒是什么呢
愤怒是一种力量的幻觉
大家打出来
愤怒是力量的幻觉
怎么去理解这句话呀
愤怒背后真正的动机是
我想要操控一个情况
按照我的意思去发展
你比方说
当我要求你必须顺着我走
而你不愿意的时候
我的掌控欲被挫败了
于是愤怒立刻就会被点燃
那换句话说
愤怒往往不是事情本身带来的
而是源于我们他必须必须怎么样
这么一个欲望
所以想要减少你的愤怒
秘诀就在于减少控制别人的欲望
大家打出来
你想不发脾气特别简单
减少控制别人的欲望
就这么一句话啊
大家想想是不是这样
你没有了控制别人的欲望
你不会发脾气
对吧你选择留下来你就留
你不留下来你就走
我也可以过得很好
是吧
啊
所以一个人越执着于别人
必须按照自己的方式来走
他就越容易在生活里边气急败坏
那该怎么做呢
我跟你们说
最好的榜样就是水
水它是一种奇妙的存在
你看
任何东西都能够挡住水的一部分
对吧你放一块石头也好
你立一块木板也好
它都要绕路走
水不会硬碰硬
它总能找到新的方向
流向该去的地方
最后你会发现
它并没有因为障碍而停下
反而凭着柔软的力量
它可以走得更远
这个就是至柔才是至刚的道理啊
所以真正有力量的人
他不需要大喊大叫
也不需要不停的炫耀
甚至都不需要用愤怒去压制谁
他们懂得容许
懂得流动
就像水一样
不必争最终能够达到目的地
所以你问我
管理情绪最好的方式是什么
那我告诉你
不是要压抑你的怒气
而是放下控制
让自己像水一样的柔软
这个时候你才发现
柔软才是真正的力量啊
你想一想
一个人若总是急着证明自己强大
其实
不是刚刚暴露了他内心的力量不足吗
一个真正内心有底气的人
他往往会更平和
更包容哪怕在家庭关系里边
他也能给别人留出空间
而不是靠怒气去维持这种掌控
所以当你学会像水一样的流动
你就会发现
愤怒再也抓不住你了
所以学会像水一样
我们就不会被愤怒所绑架了
生活里边
除了愤怒
还有一个情绪
叫做焦虑
焦虑
焦虑呢这个东西啊
他不像愤怒那么外显
啊
它更像是一种内心的持续消耗
它会让你担心未来
会让你失眠
会让你心慌
是吧所以
要解决焦虑
我跟大家说
仅仅只是靠这种放下还不够
我们需要确确实实的一些方法啊
那接下来教给大家3个方法
好不好啊
就是让你把最坏的情况看透嘛
找到具体的方法嘛
怎么去解决自己的
焦虑
我们直播间有没有特别焦虑的同学
觉得自己很焦虑的
打个一字来
啊
有焦虑的打个一字来啊
不管年龄多大
有没有九月说他是吧
有焦虑是吧
啊
number three说他有焦虑
嗯南烛红
恩嗯露露
成长的代价
你这名字都是焦虑
哈哈哈
最近很焦虑
德芙说是吧
啊那我们来听一听吧
有同学说严重焦虑
叶宁说啊
叶宁也经常5天特训也上完了吧
啊
现在少了是吧
我就是典型的焦虑型依恋
嗯
有过焦虑过是吧
取经也是
嗯
孩子有
都已经躯体化了
那你要来听一听这三个方法呀
来没有加关注的同学来
咱们加一波关注
来啊点一点上面的订阅啊
点点我们的
这个
上了5天特训营好多了是吧
那太好了啊
对大家点点这个关注
然后再点一下那个小灯牌啊
把灯牌都亮起来
我看刚刚打一的同学都没有亮灯牌啊
学习后基本上没有了
那这个效果挺不错的呀
昨晚和女儿一起上老师的亲子关系课
触动了内心
母女两任督二脉都被打通
轻松幸福开心舒服瞬间都涌上心头
太好了啊太好了
所以昨天晚上我们也讲了对吧
养育是一种互相的成就
啊
晴晴你也可以继续再看一看
这个亲子关系的这个课程啊
如何挽救和孩子的关系的51节课
好好去听一听
我觉得那个对你的帮助应该很大啊
特别是对吧
恢复这种和孩子的关系啊
现在每天都感觉挺轻松是吧
那就好啊
我老是会想外面老婆
有
有啥子没有安全感了啊
自卑
昨晚的课感动死我了
哈哈啊
OK我们来讲一讲焦虑
好不好啊
焦虑是现代人最常见的情绪
无论工作压力
创业风险
还是在生活里边大大小小的决定
总有一些事让我们心里边发慌
夜不能眠
可是焦虑就真的没有办法了吗
其实有一个非常实用的方法
可以让你快速的把焦虑给降下来
先请你想一想
你现在最焦虑的一件事是什么
来大家打在评论区来
你们现在你觉得最焦虑的事是什么
告诉我来
一句话一句话概括
一句话概括
啊
昨晚是我们5天特训的课啊
5天特训营
2025年的一新的5天特训营
孩子休学赚钱
身体健康
疾病诊断okay
嗯
大家可以打一打来
最让你焦虑的是什么
你现在最焦虑的一件事
自控力
觉得自己没有自控力很焦虑是吗
女儿网贷啊
害怕老婆出轨
嗯
还有什么
单位有一个老师傅
不知道为啥总打压我
孩子毕业找工作嗯
生存危机
身体健康
书法比赛
你看书法比赛
儿子的婚姻
孩子的健康
没钱
哈哈哈
孩子工作不稳定
孩子有品行障碍患者
女儿总是指责我
我很难过
成长缓慢
为什么要长那么快呢
亲人啊孩子学习
孩子晚睡
吃垃圾食品啊
你看你们这么多的恐惧啊
那我觉得今天这些方法
你们真的应该听一听
来啊
就是你们在心里默默的想一想
然后给你的焦虑打一个分数
好不好
从1分到10分
最严重的是10 分
你们觉得现在的你的焦虑是多少分
来打在评论区来
1-10分你们打一个分数来
焦虑是不是也可以投射
当然可以投射
一个焦虑的妈妈
能带出一个不焦虑的孩子
那才是见了鬼
啊
我都这个年纪
孩子还说我未成年
10岁以下
嗯
孩子晚睡吃垃圾食品是7分
对于他来说
同学们你看
7分啊
对你们把这个分数打打出来
记住这个分数
那么接着跟着我走三步
第一步
你问自己最坏的可能性是什么
来
回答我
你孩子吃垃圾食品
最坏的可能性是什么
ah
死掉吗太夸张了
吃垃圾食品应该死还是很难的吧
啊
对吧
最坏的可能性是什么
焦虑往往来自于不确定感
大家把这句话打一打
焦虑是来自于不确定感
我们害怕的不是事情本身
而是模糊不清的后果
是不是这样
所以
我们直接就把最坏的情况摆在台面上
咱们就别逃避了
想清楚最糟糕的情况是什么
反而能够帮你把那团模糊的恐惧
给具体化
这是第一步
第二步
你要想三个不同的方法
让这个最坏的可能性不出现
或者是即便出现了
也能够在你可承受的范围以内
比方说有同学说担心没钱
对吧有同学担心创业失败
那你能做什么呢
第一
提前准备资金
第二降低成本
灵活试错
第三
找一个导师或者找一个伙伴支持你
对吧只要有这3个方法
你会发现自己不是完全无力
还是有路可走的
这是第二步
啊
第二步记住了吗
想3个不
同的方法
那么第三步是什么呢
第三步你再问自己
我能不能提前做一些安排
就算最坏的情况真的发生了
我依然能够承受
你比方说你担心丢了工作嘛
你可以先存下来三个月的生活费
或者是学一项新的技能
让自己随时都有这个plan b
对吧就是b计划
那么我再加上一个东西
三个方法
再加一个
这个东西是什么呢行动
行动来
大家打字来
行动是对抗焦虑最好的解药
大家打出来
安心说网贷已经成瘾
好事啊
你现在网贷这个东西出来的时间不长
你再过20年你再看一看
所以在这种东西的前期
你已经有这种免疫力了
回头能理解吗
啊
嗯
行动是对抗焦虑最好的解药
所以写下你的第一步
并立刻开始执行
那这样的话
你的手里边就有了一个3+1嘛
对吧三个方法
避免或者减轻最坏的结果
和你能承受的底线
再加上一个行动的安排
就这3+1 就能够让你心情安定很多
你现在再回头看看刚才的焦虑
你再来给他打个分
我相信你会发现分数已经下降了
所以焦虑是什么
焦虑就是我担心某一些事会出现
而且这些事是我应付不了的
所以我必须要做一些事
但是我也不知道该做什么
所以我就会很焦虑
对不对
所以焦虑不是来自于事情本身
而是你觉得自己无能为力
可是你当你有了计划
有了选择
我告诉你
焦虑自然就会减少
所以大家记住
焦虑不是要你躲避
而是在提醒你要准备
你不需要等到完全没焦虑才开始行动
正因为行动
焦虑才会慢慢的消失啊
我这么说大家能理解吗
啊
哼
是不是这样
有没有收获
有收获帮钟鸣老师点点赞
来啊
没有加灯牌的大家把灯牌亮一亮
安心啊什么的
美美啊不忘初心呐
啊
把灯牌亮一亮
没方向写3个方向啊
不是教你那第一招吗
hmm
很多同学说我对这个没兴趣
对那个没有兴趣
问题不在于你对什么没有兴趣
问题在于你没有专注于你眼前的事
这个是最大的问题
不是因为喜欢而专注
恰恰相反
是你专注了
你才会喜欢这件事
你专注于钓鱼
你就会越来越喜欢钓鱼
对吧你专注于打高尔夫
你就越来越喜欢打高尔夫
你的高尔夫就会打的越来越好
你专注于做短视频
你慢慢就知道怎么拍
怎么剪怎么发
怎么去看这个流量
是不是这样
啊
方向不是别人给你的
是你有没有在专注做眼下
眼前的这件事
才是最重要的呀
啊
hmm
遇见事儿往坏处想
这是怎么回事儿
这我说过啊以前
为什么遇事总会往坏处想啊
因为心里边没有钻石嘛
啊
所以你只能看到事情坏的一面
这是一种被害妄想
也是一种强迫啊
强迫的背后是恐惧的
就是有很多的这种创伤
慢慢的慢慢的
你要学会跟它共存
理解吗
啊
是吧
就是有了这些方法
刚才那个3+1的方法
我告诉你
焦虑它确实会减轻
但有时候呢
有时候情绪来得太快对吧
可能你的理性跟不上
那么这个时候需要的是
能够有一个立刻稳定你情绪的
这么一个急救法
我跟你们说一个急救法吧
啊
重要的场合对吧
比如说会议啊
演讲啊或者是谈话呀
之前你没有时间去分析了
写计划对吧
只能快速的平静下自己的情绪
所以这个时候
有一个非常实用的身体的小技巧
可以在2分钟以内帮你调整情绪
让你恢复这个平稳
3+1 你回头再来听吧
回头再来补课
刚刚讲完了啊
大家可以加一下松明老师频道的会员
啊我们的直播回放会放到我们的呃
这个频道会员里边啊
每一周都会更新啊
所以如果错过了我们的直播
我们会给大家加上字幕
让你们学得更好啊
嗯
老师如果一段感情分不开
在一起内耗
怎么自救
最近抑郁呢
我跟你说
没有一段感情是分不开的
你认为它分不开你才会内耗
有分不开的感情吗
你自己给自己限定了一个
一个信念
这个信念才让你痛苦啊
能理解吗
啊
得不到对吧
逃不了
接纳不了
控制不了
你不抑郁谁抑郁啊
你不想分开
我该怎么办
有孩子
我们今天早上刚刚说了第一对吧
一开场我就说了这个呀
啊
跟孩子没关系
能理解吗
啊
我不知道你有没有这样的时刻
就是身体特别疲惫
状态特别的低迷
心里边烦躁不安
甚至可能一点小事都能触动你的情绪
或者说你本来想认真学习
但发现你
根本静不下心来
又或者说快要开一个重要的会议
却因为刚刚发生的一点矛盾
整个人都会陷入到
这种激动和愤怒当中
这个时候很多人都会硬撑
逼自己冷静
可是往往适得其反
那么今天
我要说一个非常简单的
这么一个小技巧
可以帮助你在两三分钟之内
能够让情绪快速的平静下来
做法很简单
首先你们来跟我学一学
伸出你的双手
然后反过来
然后合掌
然后再慢慢的举回来
看到我的手了吗
这个在能量学里边我们叫挂钩
挂钩你们千万不要小看这个动作
它背后的原理
就是能够帮助你身体的12条经络
重新达到平衡
你们可以试一试
不用用力太猛
就是当你的身体能量被打通的时候
人自然就会安静下来
所以有一点很重要
就是这个方法你不需要太用力
越轻越好
很多人认为对吧
用力越大越有效
不是刚刚相反
用力反而会破坏这个平衡
轻轻的做效果才会最好
我见过不少人亲身体验过
有人在焦躁的几乎崩溃的状态下
做了这个动作
短短2分钟
心跳慢慢恢复正常
思绪慢慢清晰
所以有些长期受到睡眠困扰的朋友
他也发现坚持用这个方法
至少一半以上的睡眠问题
都得到了改善
因为当身体的能量顺畅
我告诉你
你的心也会随之的安稳
你可以把它当做一个情绪的急救法吧
你比方说你马上要开一个重要的会
但是心里边因为一件事气得发抖
完全无法专注的时候
这个时候
你花个2分钟
做一个我们刚才这个挂钩的动作
你会惊讶于自己恢复平静的速度
哈哈我跟你们说
生活里边
其实没有人能够避免情绪的起伏
但我们会学会方法
把自己从情绪的泥潭里边给拉出来
所以记住
无法
遇到无法自控和烦躁和焦虑的时候
先用2分钟让自己的身体恢复平衡
再去面对一切
啊
咳
没看到吗
我再做一遍啊
第一
伸出两只手OK
然后反过来
手背对手背
OK
然后交叉
对对对
然后可以反过来对吧
就变成这样了OK
对对对大家不要忘了
就是手交叉的时候哎
尽可能多交叉一点
然后你还可以把它转过来
对吧啊哈哈
这个简单是吧
啊是很简单啊
就是当我们掌握了这种快速
平静的技巧的时候
其实你手里边
就多了一把情绪急救的这么一个钥匙
是吧
但生活里边
还有一种常见的困扰是什么呢
就是过去的这种不开心
别人可能说一句话
做的一件事
能够反复的在你脑海里边播放
让你久久难以释怀
那怎么办呢
我跟你说
这里有3招啊
我们今天讲方法讲的特别多啊
3个方法
可以帮你迅速的把不开心的小电影
从脑子里边淡化
缩小模糊
让你能够轻松的跳出来
啊
当你不开心的时候
来听一听我们这一段话
好不好
老师我以前就是
就是什么
嗯
老师想学人性从从什么开始
你可以听听
看看我们的5天特训营
啊
这个快
我们每一个人
都有这种经历
过去身边某一些人说了这么一句话
或者做了一件事
你心里边咯噔一下
马上不开心了
更糟的是
这份不开心不只是几分钟
甚至可能会陪伴你很长的时间
有的人甚至你一想起来
能闷闷对吧
能闷闷不乐一天三天甚至几个礼拜
为什么会这样
因为人类最深刻的记忆形式
就是画面感
就是那件事一发生
它就像一段小电影一样
被录进了我们的脑子里边
以后只要你一想起
甚至是某个情节
某个细节触发到整个画面
它就会自动的播放
于是你的情绪就会立刻卷土重来
那么
我们能不能改变这段不开心的电影呢
那答案是四个字完全可以
那接下来
我会教给大家几个非常简单
却很有效的技巧
只要你愿意跟着练习
不需要别人帮忙
你自己就能够在很短的时间里
边儿明显的去减轻那份不开心
欢迎来到松明讲心理的频道
那么减轻不开心的第一步是什么呢
调整画面的距离
大家打两个字距离
距离
现在先请你在心里边想一想
最近让你不开心的一件事儿
不用说出来
在脑子里边浮现那个画面
你给这个不开心也打一个分
1分最轻
10分最痛苦
记住这个分数
那么接下来
闭上你的眼睛
把刚才的画面
想象成电视里边的一个场景
就像剧一样
正在电视机的屏幕上在播放
OK那我们现在开始做练习
想象你把电视机往远处推来
越推越远
越来越远
直到画面变成现
在对面的一块小屏幕
你发现什么了
有没有心里边已经轻松了一些
你可以再顽皮一点
你再把它拉近
你再去看看细节
会不会感觉又沉重了呀
那我跟你说
这就是秘诀
画面越近
你的情绪越重
画面越远
你的情绪就越轻
这说明什么
说明我们的这种情绪感受
其实和画面的距离紧密相关
你刚刚体验到的
就是你大脑最自然的反应
那么第二步
调整画面的大小
大家打两个字大小
我们继续啊
请你再闭上你的眼
回到刚才的画面来
想象这是一台很大的电视机
可能是85寸
甚至更大
你能非常清晰的看到画面的细节
所以你的情绪也很明显
对吧
那么现在请你慢慢的转动这个按钮
让屏幕一点一点的缩小
一点一点的缩小
再缩小从85到75
从75寸到65寸到55寸
从55寸到35寸
再缩小到只有一个iPad那么大
然后像手机屏幕一样
画面还在呀
你依然能够看清发生过什么
但因为它缩小了
你告诉我
你的情绪有没有感觉轻松一些
那么这就是第二个方向的调整
画面越小
情绪越轻
就像我们回看这种旧照片
照片再真实
也不会让你痛苦的像当时那样
为什么因为它变小了呀
退到了你心里边的远处
那么这是第二第三个
色彩
调整画面的色彩
请大家再回到一开始那个画面来
可能是彩色的
非常清晰
对吧
那现在想象
你的手里边有一个调色的旋钮
按一下他就能从彩色慢慢的调淡
然后慢慢的变成黑白
继续再往下调
让黑白变得越来越模糊
越来越灰
甚至糊成一片
你会发现什么
画面越模糊
你的情绪就越轻
你的这种痛苦感就越来越少
对吧
这就是第三个技巧
通过调整画面的清晰度和色彩
来减弱它对你情绪的影响
那最后我再给大家一个bonus
把画面变成照片
就是刚才
你脑海里边一直是一段动态的画面
就像电影
是视频是影片
对吧现在想象起
你拿起了相机
对着电视屏幕咔嚓
把它拍下来
你会发现
动态的画面变成了一张静止的照片
照片还在
但是他没有了动作和声音
情绪的强度也随之下降
这个在心理学里边
我们把它叫做解构记忆
他没有抹掉事情
而是改变了你和这件事之间的
心里的距离
为什么这些方法有效啊
有些同学可能会疑惑
这只是想象
为什么真的可以让我轻松啊
我跟你们说
因为我们的大脑
并不完全分得清真实和想象
就是你视觉记忆的力量是非常强大的
你在脑子里边播放画面
它就会像真的发生一样
会触发真实的情绪反应的
反过来如果你刻意去调整这个画面
大脑也会随着改变你的情绪反应
所以那份不开心就不会那么强烈了
这是什么呢
这个叫NLB
神经语言
程序学里边最常用的这么一个技巧
通过调整内在的表征
来改变你的情绪体验
你现在再问问自己来
一开始你给那份不开心打了多少分啊
你再看看现
在你会发现分数下降了吧
也许从10分掉到了7分
或者从8分掉到了4分
这个就是变化的力量
当然这个练习并不是说一次
咱们就能够彻底的消除这种不开心
或者焦虑
但是它会帮你在关键的时刻
学会不被情绪绑架
我跟你说一次不够你可以重复的方法
只要熟了我告诉你
效果会越来越明显
那这套方法
不仅能够用在朋友的矛盾上
还能用在这种婚姻冲突
包括这种工作压力
甚至是过去的遗憾里边
你比方说你被同事误解
心里边很委屈的时候对吧
你和伴侣吵架
总是翻来覆去想他那句话的时候
或者是你因为某个过去的决定
反复自责的时候
你这些
你都可以用这套方法
来去减低你的情绪
他不是要你忘记
而是要你学会用新的方式和过去相处
看不见的心理
看得见的心理学
那最后送给大家一句话
不开心不是不能处理
而是你没有找到方法
情绪就像影像
你是导演也是观众
你可以选择一直沉浸其中
也可以选择退后一步改变镜头
让自己轻松
所以记住生活的痛苦无法避免
但痛苦的强度永远都在你的手上
如果你觉得我们这个频道
对你来说是有帮助的
不要忘了点点关注
也可以转发一下
我相信身边有很多的人
可能因为这条影片能够改变他的一生
赠人玫瑰
手留余香
所以很多朋友
可能今天是第一次来我们的直播间啊
也教给大家了一些具体的一些方法
让大家感受到了一些心理学可能对吧
神奇的地方
所以你会发现
其实有情绪这个东西并不是很可怕
它会像一面镜子一样
不断的照出我们真正的需求
我觉得它也会像一盏灯
提醒我们应该调整的方向
最重要的是
当你懂得用方法
就不会再被情绪拖着走
而是有能力让自己重新平衡
轻松甚至是更强大
所以我希望大家不要再害怕痛苦
也不要怕焦虑
也不要怕不开心
他只是你人生路上的这么一个信号
而你记住
永远都会有选择
对吧选择如何看待
选择如何去应对
如果你今天真的收获到了
我们在评论区打三个字来轻松了
轻松了
对吧让我知道
你已经把这些方法记在心里了
也欢迎大家把这场直播
分享给有需要的人
因为可能你的这么一个分享
就能够帮到一个
正在被情绪困住的朋友真的